and and and now we we try to turn the
page on the models Garrett situation
Chris wow you were gone miles Garrett
was reinstated and one day after he got
reinstated by the league he sat down
with ESPN and he went public with his
claim that Mason Rudolph had used a
racial slur moments before miles Garrett
removed Mason Rudolph's helmet and
whacked him over the head with it and
look I don't believe the NFL is very
happy with this time line with Miles
Garrett getting back in and then
immediately stirring things up by going
public with his claim that Mason Rudolph
used a racial slur especially because
this was already out there in November
it it was leaked that miles Garrett had
raised this argument at his appeal
hearing the Steelers denied it then
Rudolph tonight it then and now it's all
stirred up again and it really got
stirred up over the weekend Kris Mike
Tomlin issued a statement supporting
Mason Rudolph Rudolph took to Twitter to
say that the claim is 1,000% Falls
bold-faced lie I did not have not and
would not utter a racial slur this is a
disgusting and reckless attempt to
assassinate my character here's my
response okay miles Garrett isn't trying
to assassinate Mason Rudolph's character
he's just a bystander and this miles
Garrett is trying to avoid becoming
Vaughn says Burford yeah exactly you
miles Garrett needs justification for
why he did what he did otherwise he is
Vaughn tez Burfict because he'd been
fine for a couple of illegal hits before
that moment and if you don't have
provocation if you don't have
justification for taking off a guy's
helmet and hit him over the head with it
you're vantes Burfict and you're flagged
with that for the rest of your career
this is why I think Garrett said what he
said and he says well I'm not saying
this to justify anything there is no
justification okay fine he wants people
who are in the court of public opinion
to hear that claim and think there was
justification there was provocation
there was reason for Garrett to do what
he did without provocation he looks like
a madman yeah yeah yes he does I mean
this this guy is a hell of a player
Miles Garrett I mean he is he is in the
conversation from one of the best
defensive players in football you know
to what you're saying you're right he's
saying it more about protecting himself
than trying to really accuse Mason
Rudolph but the problem is it's a low
blow and I got issues with it I do I
mean to me it's just yeah and again uh
if that word was said then screw Mason
Rudolph and I'll never say a good thing
about him ever again in my life but the
way this went down to me does not show
that I can sit here and just necessarily
you know take Miles Garrett at his word
I can't
you know first off with if that type of
thing happened you know this is where I
would back up what Mike Tomlin said you
know if that word was said we would have
heard this right after the game he would
have said this to the Prescott in this
press conference at his locker when he
was talking to everybody this is too big
of a thing - I think you would also hurt
other guys in the field who were close
by who would echo it even teammates if
he if Mason Rudolph went there I would
expect somebody like Pouncy or whoever
it is to be like ah no you know Mason
did some things he might not out them
but I would expect them to kind of show
us some way that you know Mason maybe
deserve to get clocked over the head
some somehow some way there's none of
that so that to me is wrong and then
this to Mike this is the other part that
bothers me you know when Miles Garrett
first told the NFL behind closed door
his first comment was oh they told me
that wasn't gonna get out you know to me
that's fishy in itself as well like I
I'm gonna say this and I'm hoping is
gonna stay behind closed doors because
it's not really real and I don't want to
become public now so I don't want to get
out he wanted to get out because he
wanted the average person to possibly
look at that evidence and say now I know
why he removed the guy's helmet and hit
him over the head with it nothing that
makes it right but now I know why he did
it right because otherwise there's no
reason for it otherwise you do look like
there's something wrong with you that
you would blow a fuse that easily and do
something that heinous on a football
field and you know Kris let's apply
common sense here even if miles Garrett
isn't prepared in the aftermath of that
game to explain why he did what he did
hey you know he was so calm I got to
commonsensical up points to make one at
his locker he was calm he said I lost my
cool I mean you know what if that's what
was said
he should still be mad right he's not to
be mad at man he's not even not in that
clip we're showing right there
you know I think the actions of a guy
that was just called a word like that
that is so egregious and horrible in our
society and in general that he would be
yelling things right there as he's being
pushed back by the Steelers if that was
the case you would see rage on him then
you don't see that to your point sorry
to cut you off I didn't mean to do but
here's the other point - even if he
doesn't mention it at the postgame press
conference he's in the locker room with
52 other guys exactly guys are gonna be
asking him right why did you do what you
did right why did you it would have got
it would have gotten out it would have
been everywhere it would have been more
than just maybe somebody who got word as
to what one of the arguments is gonna be
at the appeal hearing it would have been
50 different players know about it and
they're telling 50 different people in
the media about it or their agents or
whoever it would have been rampant by
the weekend if that was something that
miles Garrett was telling his teammates
in the immediate aftermath of the event
happened the mere fact that it didn't
happen and this is this is kind of what
meshes with my Tomlin's right right like
I I would have heard something about yes
it's just common sense something like
that goes down you're gonna hear about
it before it gets mentioned a week later
at the guys appeal hearing period right
that I think that's exactly and you know
listen again Miles Garrett's a young man
he's still learning
I hope he's learned from this and he
continues to you know become a better
person a better player all those things
I mean he's a superstar of our league I
don't think this is a guy that has like
true meanness in his heart I don't I
think this a guy that just lost his cool
in a weird situation and I'm not trying
to like totally let Mason Rudolph be a
skate you know get away scot scot-free
here either yeah was he on the ground
kicking a little bit and trying to rip
miles Garrett helmet off certainly but I
still would go back to miles Garrett
started the issue to me and I wish if we
could show the play in totality if we
have it in the back control room because
again Mason Rudolph throws a ball to his
left
miles Garrett sees him throw the ball I
mean this is a very high level aware
football player okay we're then seeing
it he's
still tries to hit mason rudolph and
knows he's thrown the ball and then
won't let go the balls gone for one
count two counts almost three counts and
he's still holding on to mason rudolph
and mason ruff threw the ball right by
his face an ear hole as he threw it so
he surely saw it so that he gave mason
rudolph the business thereby holding on
and just and then he looked like he got
frustrated that he didn't bring him to
the ground and he just kept holding him
that made up mason rudolph was certainly
in the wrong by kicking and throwing a
little fit and trying to maybe rip his
helmet off but miles Garrett pushed it
to another level as we know and that's
where it was the game was over in the
fourth quarter of a close game right
Yeah right so yeah that's that's where
it just is a little I guess you know
fishy it's fishy I I tend to believe
like what Mike and there's the play see
me through there's no way he didn't see
him throw the ball and he wouldn't let
go of them and then of course the little
scrum goes out and then miles Garrett
just goes entirely too far with the play
in general and you know like I said I
want to make it perfectly clear if Mason
Rudolph said that word then screw Mason
Rudolph and I'll never root for you
again but to me miles Garrett
explanation is fishy at the very least
at this point at this standpoint I would
like what Mike Tomlin said in his quote
Mason Rudolph's lawyer also took to
Twitter over the weekend and all these
developments happen on Saturday the Mike
Tomlin statement the Mason Rudolph tweet
and then Timothy younger who represents
Mason Rudolph issued a lengthy statement
and the big takeaway is there could be a
lawsuit filed against Miles Garrett for
defamation of character not the easiest
thing to do when you're a public figure
and even though Mason Rudolph isn't a
very good quarterback he's still a
public figure he has to show actual
malice and what that means is he has to
show that Miles Garrett knew the
statement was false or acted with
reckless disregard to whether or not the
statement was true or false and you
could argue hey miles why are you
repeating this contention when you've
seen and heard the reaction from the
news that came out of the appeal hearing
Mason Rudolph denied it then the
Steelers denied it then what have you
done to investigate whether or not maybe
you just misheard and and I don't rule
out Kris the possibility there's a
possibility slim as it may be
that miles Garrett thinks he heard
something that wasn't sure sure yeah
now the details of his story are a
little bit fishy and I think a lawyer
could really make hey there to eliminate
the idea that he mistakenly heard
something that wasn't said I mean but
the bottom line is the lawyer is
rattling the sword
it doesn't mean a lawsuit will be filed
but the lawyer believes there's enough
there to proceed and you also have the
potential for a battery case against
Miles Garrett even though you weren't
injured as Mason Rudolph you still were
hit over the head with your own helmet
yeah and if you're gonna have a jury
decide this whole case you want that
video to be Exhibit A you want the jury
to watch that and say what's wrong with
that guy and that's the same group
that's going to be deciding whether or
not Miles Garrett has to compensate
Mason Rudolph or any injury to his
reputation because there will be people
out there casual fans non-fans people
who just hear this there will be people
who assume that Mason Rudolph said it
and that Mason Rudolph is walking around
with some sort of racial bias in his
heart well yeah I mean if you you know
again and you know I know people are
already trying to point that out with
Mason Rudolph whitter history and
comments he's made there and things like
that you know that so yes there it's
it's opened up a can of worms as far as
you know his life his personal life
people were judging them now when you
throw out that kind of statement by
Miles Garrett you know so we'll see I
don't know wild miles Garrett brought it
up again you know I guess he feels that
strongly about it and he wants to you
know clear his name to a degree I hope
you learned from this and again but it
just it just doesn't line up to me right
now from what I've seen the facts at
this point the reaction after the game
those things do not line up to a guy who
used a racial slur and then the other
guy acting the way he did yes he was mad
on the field but yet no remorse all the
things you said about in the locker room
players aren't saying it nothing like
that no coaches are saying it on the
field to Mike Tomlin right after the
game the miles Garrett said this and
blah blah blah
none of that went down and that to me is
where it is fishing and again like I
said if Mason Rudolph did say it then
he's a horrible person and
we'll never root for him again and
here's the other practical side of it
too for the Steelers it's not like this
accusation is being made against Ben
Roethlisberger we're teammates would
feel compactly two privately it's a guy
it's a guy that hey you know what
you stink anyway right and if you said
it get the hell out of here right yeah
exactly you get out of it and listen I
know the Pouncy twins the bouncy twins
are like the most honest real guys you'd
ever meet in your life they really are
there there is no fluff they're good
people they really are they got a great
way about wait wait are you talking
you're talking about the same guys that
were the free Aaron Hernandez be clear
well you're right okay fair and balanced
your rather than that yes well you know
okay again this is it they were in a
tough spot there it was a guy that they
grew up with and we're in college with
and good friends so they were trying you
know I think at that point they weren't
sure what was going on okay I think they
realized that you know I probably at
this point yes okay but I'm just saying
they're very real honest guys and the
type of guys that I don't think would
let you know their backup quarterback to
what you're saying get away with that
statement III don't think they would let
him get away with it I think you would
have heard from people in the Steelers
locker room from Pouncy who's told other
guys or whatever
hey I heard Rudolph's say this and this
it would start to leak out but we've
heard none of that like none zilch nada
and that's where again I think it's a
little fishy the whole thing the NFL
trying to keep their head low on this I
got two different emails from the league
on Saturday and I didn't even ask a
question yeah but they don't know your
reputation they want it they know the
platform baby they respect the megaphone
they wanted me to know there was no
sound recorded from the field during the
game as with every game there were
microphones on the center or interior
lineman that helped amplify the ambient
sound as the quarterbacks are calling
signals but those microphones do not
record sound microphones are open from
the break of the huddle through the snap
of the ball and I also suggested that
the NFL could have investigated this
separately they could have brought in
Miles Garrett and Mason Rudolph and
grilled them and come to a conclusion as
a who's telling the truth like they do
in a personal conduct policy
investigation the league didn't do that
but the league pointed out to me that
they checked with the officiating crew
including the referee who was on top of
the play and the ensuing aftermath no
player on either team came forward to
say they heard Rudolph say it on the
field there was also no indication of
any players saying they heard Rudolph
say it in their postgame comments but
again they very easily could have
brought in Rudolph and brought in
Garrett and put them under the hot light
and asked them a bunch of tough
questions and come to a conclusion based
upon the demeanor the statements the
explanation everything who's sweating
who's not everything that you use to
determine who's telling the truth and
they could have come to inclusion on
this they just don't want to do it this
is a rabbit hole they don't wanna go
down this is something they don't want
to have to deal with
and thanks to miles Garrett they now
have to deal with it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports